what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel okay so picking up with
Injustice year 3 uh we take a little bit
of a different approach than what we've
done so far with regards to the
Injustice series and I actually really
like it I mean comic books are like
anything else you know if you stick with
the same thing long enough eventually it
grows mundane you got to have freshness
you got to have something new you got to
inject some new blood you got to change
things otherwise I don't know about you
guys but I just sto caring about reading
the same old thing all the time and
while I wouldn't say that like in
jestice years 1 and two were like the
same old thing all the time I like the
idea of sort of nipping it in the butt
right like throwing in some new stuff
before we even begin to get to the point
where we're ready to see something new
it just keeps us on our toes it keeps
things fresh and that's why I love about
the way the Tom Taylor does this and
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be focusing on Magic wielders
and we pick up with John Constantine now
this is so cool because Constantine has
always been kind of like the this off
again on again main DC guy in the sense
that he's you know been alongside the
traditional DC superheroes with like
justice league dark different things
like that but then he's also had his own
you know going off fighting angels and
demons that kind of thing in like the
vertigo hellblazer line of comics and
we'll talk about vertigo here in a
second in terms of how it relates to
this especially when we get to Tron but
the idea here is that John Constantine
is kind of like you know one of these
guys who looks around and says after
this massive battle between the Green
Lanterns and and the sinestral core you
know it left a lot of people dead and
there was a lot of collateral damage one
of the people who was killed was the
mother of Constantine's daughter Rose
Constantine now it was kind of this
weird situation because John was
basically keeping her hidden now of
course we know that the reason why Jon
did this is because he's got a lot of
enemies out there a lot of enemies who
are very very powerful in the realm of
you know sorcery and and magic and so on
and so forth keeping Rose hidden away
from the world putting a lot of magical
enchantments on the house in which she
resided was a way of keeping those
individuals out there who would seek to
do John harm keep them from locating his
daughter and using her as a tool the
problem with this is that with the
destruction of this house also came the
elimination of these magical
enchantments and so his daughter in a
lot of ways is a Sitting Duck and that's
the cool thing about this this is
something that I really want you guys to
keep in the back of your head because at
the end of all this we're going to find
out not everything's what it seems which
is pretty badass this is actually a
really really cool story but um but this
this is interesting you know because
John basically grabs his daughter and
says look we need to find a way to get
her out of this because again you got to
keep in mind Superman's regime stretches
everywhere I mean his his goal is to
take over the world and that means
everyone everywhere on the world will
see things his way including the magic
wielders somewhere along the line but
this also begs an interesting question
how would Superman deal with them
because remember when it comes to
Superman like one of his major
weaknesses is magic I mean that's that's
kind of his that's kind of his big thing
and so what happens is Constantine
basically takes his daughter to the
Tower of Fate because remember we've
talked about this in year two and year
one the Tower of Fate basically exists
outside of all space and time and it's
like this one safe haven for magic
wielders that people just aren't really
able to access in the traditional sense
now of course when he arrives here it
kind of takes you know Dr Fate it takes
Zana by surprise but it's really cool
because we get this sort of we we really
follow Constantine as we do this sort of
Journey gathering around these different
aspects of of really like magic within
the DC Universe and that's what makes
this so cool is it really just focuses a
lot on Magic wielders of course what we
do is we follow Constantine when he's
teleported by zatana to find detective
chimp now detective chimp man I love
detective
chimp he's one of my favorite guys and
the cool thing about this is he's kind
of like relegated to this realm of magic
wielders right I mean he has crossed
with Batman he has worked alongside
Batman Bruce Wayne realizes just how
intelligent you know detective chimp is
he's one of the smartest guys in the
entirety of the DC Universe but it's
really really cool to see him here
because we're going to see this like
mixed Alliance that we wouldn't normally
see but that works out pretty well but
from here what we do is we follow
Constantine where he basically goes to
visit Tron now Tron is an interesting
situation in the realm of DC because
what Tom Taylor says is we're basically
going to hell but this is kind of a
misnomer Tron is like a demon Lord but
he's not like Satan like he's not like
like the the devil I mean the devil is
Lucifer Morning Star but that creates an
interesting situation in DC Comics
because the way the DC works is you've
got like your traditional DC heroes the
one that you guys think of like Superman
Batman Wonder Woman the Justice League
you know Green Lantern so on and so
forth all the way down to guys like
Constantine to a degree vertigo is where
you find a lot of the angels and Demon
stuff but the issue is that they I don't
really think there's ever been an
instance where they've ever actually
like crossed over where it's been like
Batman versus Lucifer Morning Star but
vertigo is where you find the
traditional Angelic Pantheon where you
have like judeo Christianity based uh
Angels demons so on and so forth that
was one of the big starts for for
Constantine you ask where some of the
best hellblazer stories are at the issue
with this is that within the traditional
Pantheon really within Injustice itself
as it stands right now we could
basically look at Tron and say that he's
probably the most powerful or at least
one of the most powerful beings here in
terms of his abilities I mean he's
capable of like matter manipulation you
know reality warping I mean it's it's
insane he could take out Superman almost
instantaneously no questions asked I
mean it's that kind of level of power
but with John Constantine being here of
course somewhere along the line and we
don't really know how but somewhere
along the line Trion had gotten a piece
of John Constantine's Soul which means
that when Constantine dies he'll be
bound to the realm of Tron and just
tortured you know for for Millennia and
Millennia and Millennia but the cool
thing is that Constantine seems to be
buying time here where he basically says
hey look I have information about your
daughter now this strikes Tron as
extremely important because remember as
the daughter of Tron Raven is like the
key to Tron basically invading Earth you
know it's almost like you know she's the
gatekeeper she's the one you know
barring the door if she were to be
suaded you know persuaded to to tron's
side it would open the door for Tron to
launch a full-scale demonic invasion of
Earth and then there goes the
neighborhood and so it creates like this
really really interesting situation
because it's like man like you know if
Constantine's willing to turn over Raven
to Tron then that means that yeah sure
Tron could take down Superman but then
the Earth just like descends into
absolute Madness and devilry after that
like I mean it's you know it's it's it's
cutting off your nose to spite your face
basically and so because of this
Constantine's basically striking a deal
Tron says if you have information about
my daughter find her bring her to me and
then we'll talk now from here we switch
over to the Hall of Justice and again
you know this whole Hall of Justice
thing it's just kind of Fallout it's not
a great big huge thing you know but it's
the idea that uh that neither Sinestro
nor Superman or any of those guys can
find any of their allies because
remember you know flash cyborg uh Robin
they were all taken by Bruce Wayne's
guys the reason why they can't locate
them is because they're being blocked by
Magic they're being they're being held
by Magic and Superman can't cope with
magic you know you can't see through
magical AR facts you know magical
buildings different things like that
it's really one of his major weaknesses
and so what we do is we basically pick
up with John Constantine meeting with
Batman and this is cool you know because
we have Chaz the cow driver you know of
course that shows up and Constantine
says hey man hop in we'll explain along
the way and it's hilarious because you
got Chaz and you've got Constantine who
are hanging out inside this car they
look in the back seat and they've got
Batman and detective Chimp in the back
and they just die laughing it's like
this Odd Couple in the back seat and
it's absolutely hilarious it's it's one
of these weird funny things but from
here there really just Constantine
showing Batman what's going on saying
hey look we have Raven held captive we
have her Bound in this uh sort of
magical enchantment that she can't
escape from but I'm showing you this so
that if something happens to me uh
you'll basically be able to deal with
this you'll be basically be able to keep
this going and so from here it's just
kind of traveling around and Gathering
all these different Magic wielders
Gathering as many people as they
possibly can now the crazy thing about
this is remember this is really Superman
falling further and harder than he did
before when it came to him being a bad
guy the issue with this is that Superman
basically grabs one of the policemen
that was fighting alongside Jim Gordon
uh against his forces you know when when
Jim Gordon and his whole guys were you
know fighting off Superman's soldiers
and so on and so forth and Superman
Begins to intimidate him a little bit
like he begins to threaten him a little
bit and saying hey look I know what you
are up to like I know you know what what
you've been doing I want to know where
Batman is I want to know where our
people are at Superman says look I can
see your family like I can see your kids
you know I can see your wife it would be
very easy for her to disappear it'd be
very easy for something bad to happen to
now of course we can keep that from
happening all you have to do is tell us
where our guys are now this is like bad
man I mean this is this is rough this is
Superman at at some of his most extreme
because Superman's usually always the
voice of reason and he has been in a lot
of ways even when sinestra was trying to
turn him down this path of evil Superman
was still kind of maintaining his own
bit of Sanity he was maintaining his own
level of goodness the issue with this is
that it seems like he's really crossing
the point of no return now we'll really
see how far he's fallen but before we do
what we end up really doing here is we
basically follow alongside zatana which
grabs Harley Quinn and takes the rest of
them to the home of Jason blood now
Jason blood is an interesting character
here because he like a lot of magic
wielders descends very strongly into
magic but he's a guy that's been around
for some you know however many thousands
of years but he is basically bound to a
demon by the name of etrian now his
whole history goes back all the way to
the Camelot age I mean it gets
absolutely insane you know during that
whole point with King Arthur so on and
so forth when Camelot was on the verge
of falling when Morgan Lefay not the
Morgan Lefay from Marvel Comics but when
Morgan Lefay was on the verge of seizing
Camelot for itself Merlin summoned you
know etran the demon for the purpose of
fighting on behalf of Camelot but when
it got to the point that you know it was
really Beyond any measure of hope uh
what Merlin did is he bound etran to
Jason blood and so it would just simply
be this situation that Jason blood could
simply summon rran we can he can also
feed on these different measures of of
powers and abilities and that's just
kind of the thing that we're going to
see is that in their own for or fashion
these different individuals who are part
of these magical groups have their own
abilities they have their own powers
their own capabilities sometimes they'll
use a whole lot of their powers
sometimes they'll only use one facet of
powers and that's the cool thing is Tom
Taylor doesn't give us too much too fast
he's not like here's all these magic
wheelers and here's all the powers they
have you know it's like each one has a
particular role to play and it actually
works out pretty well but at this point
it's just a matter of trying to figure
out what to do next because the big
question they have is are they going to
take out Superman the funny thing here
is that in the middle of this you know
like like John Constantine switches the
conversation over to detective chimp and
then Harvey Bullock's just like
yeah I'm
out and it's hilarious here because
Bullock's like look guys I mean let's be
a little honest like we're dealing with
people who can teleport we're dealing
with people that use magic all that kind
of stuff there's a monkey that's talking
like I'm a little bit over my head here
I'm I'm going to go home I'm going to go
back home and have a beer and it's funny
because this is Tom Taylor like
injecting us into the situation right
like if we were in this if it was like
yeah man like Superman's taking over the
world and yet somehow we're hanging out
here with talking chimps you know it's
just like guys I I need to go I I got to
go home like I just need to I'm walking
into a realm of Insanity I got to go
relax here but this is when we get Tom
Taylor kind of showing us what detective
chimp is really about because remember
detective chimp's fought alongside a lot
of different superheroes and a lot of
different you know strong people one of
which is Jim Gordon and he says look I
fought alongside Gordon I know what he
was about what he cared about were the
victims the victims always came first if
Jim Gordon fought for for anything it
was the victims if for nothing else he
was fighting on behalf of making sure
the victims received some measure of
Honor you know some measure of really
Justice for the crimes that were
committed against him and he says you're
a cop be a cop set your mind aside for a
second you know and accept the fact that
you're dealing with a a world that you
never really knew about that you never
really experienced before yeah I'm a
talking chimp but I'm just like Jim
Gordon I always fought on behalf of the
victims stay on behalf of the victims
and so what happens is that in the
middle of all this the seal for the
house of Jason blood is broken and the
question people have is who is this who
could possibly track them down who could
basically figure out where they're at
and would have the power to overcome
these enchantment now in the realm of DC
there's you can count the number of
people who could do that on one hand
because we're talking about people that
wield magic that very few people can
compete with not to mention all these
different enchantments that they've put
on this location you know only the most
powerful beings could achieve this and
what we find out is that where Jason
blood goes to summon the form of rran to
basically keep you know to use this
Demon's powers for the purpose of
keeping them safe that where Jason blood
is obliterated along with Harvey bulock
that the person that was tracking them
down is the Spectre the spirit of
Vengeance when I saw this I was like
holy [__] pardon my language I was like
wow the Spectre the spirit of Vengeance
now this is a huge deal this is wildly
important and the reason why is because
remember in the realm of DC Comics the
Spectre is the Vengeance of God I mean
it is a level of power hitherto unseen
when the Spectre gets involved it means
things are going to like things are
going to go down like some bad stuff is
going to some folks are not going to
make it out some folks are not going to
survive the experience now with regards
to this detective chimp is essentially
injured in in the middle of all this the
problem is that magic really seems to be
the only one that's binding him to some
measure of life now that's going to kind
of be the common theme is of course you
know they're able to bring detective
chimp back but magic is what's keeping
him alive if he leaves the realm of
magic he will effectively die and so
what happens is they basically you know
you have zatana you have a handful of
people who basically try to whisk them
away you know who basically try to take
you know get them out of there and take
them back to the Tower of Fate it's
really just kind of going into retreat
but while this happens Batman goes out
to talk to the Spectre now this is
awesome because it's like it's like
Batman has balls man but you also have
to keep in mind too when it comes to the
when it comes to the Spectre Batman's
well familiar you know he's he's very
familiar with the Spectre granted the
Injustice universe is a little bit
different like I imagine in this
injustice Injustice Universe Emerald
Twilight never happened so how Jordan
never became the Spectre but it doesn't
matter because Batman still fought
alongside the Spectre he's still been
alongside the Spectre he knows about Jim
Corgan he knows about this this whole
aspect that the Spectre is still human
at his base form he's just imbued with
the with the with the Vengeance of God
and so it's really kind of cool here
because while Batman's talking to the
Spectre and while he is making a little
bit of progress you know zatana
basically whisks everybody away to the
Tower of Fate well then the Spectre is
just like deceive her like he freaks you
know he's like you're here to trick me
like that's what you're here to do you
were here to be a distraction you were
here to to fool me of course Zana whisk
Batman away before the Spectre just
obliterates him but now Batman and his
forces have to contend with the fact
that the Spectre the Vengeance of God
seems to be working on behalf of
Superman this is where the plot gets
thicker because it's like when it comes
to someone like the Spectre what do you
do against this what do you do against
that kind of ability it's it's literally
the hand of God like what do you do when
you're fighting against the hand of God
like how do you combat that now this is
kind of the cool thing here is remember
because magic because of it's designed
to work against Angels and Demons they
can basically shield things they can
hide things the Spectre is limited to
the existence of space and time and so
it's almost like a road you know if the
entire concept of space and time in the
DC Universe is like a highway the
Spectre cannot walk into the grassy area
the grassy area is where the Tower of
Fate's at that's where they're all
hiding out at and so they're basically
moving into territory that the Spectre
can't access or can't see into on his
own he can't find them they've basically
all gone into the high weeds and so
because of this we switch back over to
the Hall of Justice now this is why I
say Superman's Fallen pretty damn far
because Sinestro is torturing this cop
you know to gain information on where it
is that Batman and his forces have taken
Barry Allen where they've taken cyborg
Robin so on and so forth and and and
Superman initially steps in the way and
says hey look man you got to stop you
can't torture this guy we don't do that
in response Sinestro says no you don't
do that but he says in time s of War you
do what you have to do to gain the kind
of information that you need you know he
says you got more important things you
got to go focus on go focus on those
more important things let me do what I'm
best at and Superman says okay he says
fine he walks away and he lets Sinestro
torture a guy and that's one of the the
worst things about this is It's Superman
willing to let a guy torture a man a
human being the people that Superman was
sworn to protect he's letting Sinestro
torture them now of course this entire
situation is met with the arrival of
Spectre and Spectre says hey man I'm
here to warn you I'm here to tell tell
you that there are magical forces
working against you and this is when Tom
Taylor makes things clear right you know
this is when Tom Taylor says look I as a
spectre am on your behalf I believe in
your cause I'm the spirit of Vengeance
you know my goal is to make sure that
people who are evildoers are basically
brought to Justice you know because of
that if you are bringing about a world
of Peace you're doing what I've always
been seeing you know what I've always
sought to do what I've always tried to
do you're basically solving my problem
for me and so the spirit of Vance you
know the the Spectre sides with Superman
here but the funny thing is he's like I
sense doubt in you he senses doubt out
in in Shazam this is kind of cool you
know of course Superman comes to his
friend's Aid and says hey look you know
shazam's on my side he's a good guy you
know he's one of the good guys if he
senses doubt we'll sort it out you know
and of course this is uh if he senses
doubt we'll sort it out I promise that
was not meant to be a RH but you know
the Spectre kind of lets him go but it's
just as idea that the Spectre is on
their side he's working on their behalf
but it's also him telling Superman look
these guys are using forces that I can't
really work around these guys are using
forces that I can't really defeat on my
own uh I can to a degree but the problem
is finding them in order to be able to
pull that off and so what we do is we
basically switch back to the idea of
Constantine's daughter now this is Tom
Taylor kind of you know toying with this
notion a little bit I don't really know
where he expected to take this later on
down the line I mean he really kind of
left after year three and then year four
I want to say or year four and five I
think was Brian baletto but what he does
is Tom Taylor basically reveals that the
daughter of John Constantine has magical
abilities of course she does the trick
with pulling the coin out from behind
the ear but then Dr Fate comes along and
says that was not slight of hand she
pulled that coin from another Dimension
from another plane of existence or
something she conjured it out of thin
air and as Tom Taylor basically saying
look the daughter of John Constantine is
going to have magical abilities and what
the limits of those are we don't know
but we know that she's going to going to
go on to become insanely powerful she's
going to have an insane amount of
abilities it's not wildly important to
the story but it is important enough
that I thought it was worth bringing up
now from here we switch over to Madame
Xanadu and this is actually kind of a
funny moment because John Constantine
and Batman show up you know and they're
like hey look we really need to talk to
you and Madam Z is like nope go away
like I am not talking to any of you and
it's funny because the whole thing the
whole the whole situation is madam Madam
zanadu is kind of like a cirrus right I
mean she she she does have incredible
magical abilities but her real big thing
is you know her ability to to sense what
goes on in the magical sphere and then
use tarrow cards to discern what it is
that she sees and so she's a legitimate
tarot reader she's also effectively
Immortal but she's an essential part of
the whole you know mystical aspect of
the DC Universe the problem with this is
that where her sign says enter freely
and unafraid Batman's like like she
hands a sign out to Batman and Batman
says she had a new sign made it says
inter freely and unafraid unless you're
John
Constantine which is hilarious now of
course once they actually you know once
she actually lets lets them in and they
begin talking to her you know it's like
hey look you have like we need to like
you need to be aware of what's going on
you have to know what's happening but we
also need you to give us some future
understanding of what's going on now of
course she's informed by aware by way of
her tarot readings that Jason blood is
dead and for her this is a huge
situation because the two of them go all
the way back to the age of Merlin I mean
you know Madame Xanadu has a huge
history with Merlin and following that
whole experience she basically just
spent you know however many Millennia
traveling the world and being like a
like an adviser to all these different
rulers leading her up to the modern day
involvement with suicide squads so on
and so forth you know Batwoman during
the uh new52 Batwoman run and that kind
of thing but with regards to the DC
Injustice Universe her and Jason blood
had a very strong relationship that had
gone back for quite some time the issue
with this is that she says this is the
curse of John con
anybody who spends enough time with John
Constantine will always end up dying
it's just the way that John
Constantine's Life Works that he brings
a plague among them it's just how he
functions now following this uh this
Outburst you know of course he basically
kicks out Constantine and Batman and
Constantine's like hey look man just
just give her time you know you know
just just give her 10 minutes or so you
know and then she'll be like the anger
will subside she will basically chill
and then she'll invite us back in and
sure enough that's exactly what happens
once she's over this grieving process uh
she basically says hey look there are
forces at work here the Spectre is at
work of course her being aware of what's
going on you know the Spectre is here
she takes a peak which is really the
purpose of John Constantine and Batman
coming here is using her abilities to
take a look at what's going on with
regards to the ideas of Superman's going
on behind the scenes and so on the issue
with this is that as soon as she tries
to take a peek some massive force of
energy basically blocks her out or at
least it gives her some measure of a
glimpse now on the surface we would say
maybe this is the Spectre but the
Spectre never really conducts himself
like this and so it's like someone else
either the Spectre that you know someone
that's not actually Jim Corgan or some
other Force some level and energy that's
going on there is working on behalf of
Superman as well and so what she says is
this Glimpse that I saw basically said a
dead man will fall a dead man will rise
Souls will be lost traitors will be
triumphant you know the empress will
awaken the emperor will sleep all that
kind of good stuff you know like like
Swamp Thing is going to show up the
green and all these different things but
the Joker will be born again and so it's
just like wow so the idea seems to be
that all of it's going to come full
circle again but there's so much more
coming later on down the pipe and so
what happens here is we kind of switch
back to Raven and of course you know
with Raven you know being held prisoner
here she's basically able to uh to trick
the cat you know of one of the uh of one
of the magical inhabitants to knocking
over a Candlestick and when that happens
because the candlesticks or at least
because the placement of the
candlesticks was one of the aspects that
you know maintain the enchantment that
kept her imprisoned she's basically able
to kick out or send out her astral
projection form and her astral
projection travels to go see Superman
and says hey look this is where I'm
being hidden I'm being hidden in the
power of Fate now this is kind of a
weird situation here and the reason why
I say this is because again up to this
point we've kind of been led to believe
that the Spectre is unable to see into
these different aspects of angels demons
you know that that kind of thing you
know able to unable to see into like the
mystical world but that's not entirely
true because if we go and reread the old
Spectre stories he was able to do this
time and time again he was able to
appear before magic wheelers there was
nowhere that he could that he couldn't
access and the reason why is because
he's basically imbued with all the
knowledge and not really not really all
the abilities but everything that God
knows the Spectre knows to a degree and
so because of this the Spectre knows you
know all these different safe locations
but with the Spectre saying I don't know
where they are I don't know how to
access them means that this does not
seem to be the Spectre that we're aware
of or at least that we're used to at the
same time uh the Spectre almost
immediately attacks Raven and the reason
for this is just because of the fact
that Spectre doesn't know who Raven is
it's just like what's going on like I
don't know if she's an enemy I don't
know if she's a well he knows who she is
but he doesn't know if she's an enemy or
a friend but of course Superman says hey
look she's an ally but she says I'm you
know I'm being held in Gotham like I'm
being held in Gotham City you have to
come and find me you have to free me now
this is significant and the reason why
is because when Superman's given a
glimpse of where she's at he immediately
races off but if Superman were to
basically attain Raven then it means
that he would have all kinds of demon
sorcery all kinds of you know magic
wielding on his side and it would be a
huge play Not only that once he finds
out where she's at and tries to
penetrate the building this is again
where Tom Taylor tells us the Superman
is weak like he has no ability against
magic he breaks his hand trying to break
through these magical enchantments and
so of course instead he just uses his
ring and tears the top off the place but
once he's able to locate and once he
finds Raven he basically sets her free
but what we find out is this is actually
a ruse this was not Raven instead where
John Constantine had basically moved the
body of Raven they were waiting on
Superman to get here and the reason why
they were waiting on Superman to get
here is because what they were doing is
they were using a guy by the name of
ragman to impersonate Raven now this is
kind of a weird situation here because
ragman has this weird kind of history
but basically ragman just like collects
Souls of evildoers of demons different
things like that and the goal here is to
basically wrap Superman in rags and then
absorb his soul into ragman himself
basically remove Superman from the
equation of course this fails in
spectacular fashion and the reason why
is because Superman basically tried to
call for the Spectre the issue is that
because Superman is bound inside of a
magical facility the Spectre can't
locate him the Spectre can't see him not
only that Superman's Communicator is
currently turned off and so Tom Taylor's
kind of building this situation that
there's no possible way for Superman to
attain Aid there's no possible way for
him to get help the issue is that
Constantine and his team underestimate
Superman and that's kind of the kicker
here because when they look at at the
Man of Steel they see well he's got
super strength super speed so on and so
forth but if you take away his body's
ability to move well he's just going to
be kind of useless the issue here is a
Superman's able to finagle his freedom a
slight bit activate his Communicator
call Shazam and then Billy Batson's
there in an instant and it's insane
because now it's just like oh God you
know because now you got basically have
two Superman in the same location the
other half of this is constant tells
ragman look you have to capture Billy
basson you have to capture him and you
have to take him but ragman's response
is I only take the souls of the guilty I
only take the souls of those who have
done evil I cannot take the soul of an
innocent man in response to this Shazam
uses his powers to incapacitate ragman
and then suddenly the tops blown off the
place we've got the Spectre how Jordan
and Sinestro and so it's basically a
situation where it's all hit the fan the
entire efforts of Constantine seem to be
completely out the window not only that
the Spectre takes ragman and just
destroys him in histi iry and so again
this is kind of that curse of John
Constantine living on that those who
associate with him too closely always
end up debt that those individuals who
trust John Constantine always end up
losing their lives in the process now of
course the response to Superman is to
lose his mind I mean just to be like you
really had the audacity to kidnap me and
try to hold me hostage to try to take my
soul are you serious and like he just
absolutely Freaks and his his goal is to
kill Constantine right off the bat but
of course Sinestro is the voice of
reason here and this is kind of the
interesting thing because Tom Taylor's
continuing this trend of telling us that
Superman's so emotional here like
Superman is just ridiculously
overpowered and ridiculously emotional
and so again this also shows us that
Superman is still very much under the
influence of Sinestro in the sense that
he's fallen so far that he doesn't see
Sinestro for the bad guy that he really
is and so sparing John Constantine the I
the idea here is that Constantine is the
only one that knows the location of
where their friends are at he's the only
one that knows you know how to get uh
how to get the flash how to get cyborg
how to get Robin back and so what they
do is they basically grab John
Constantine and take him back to their
you know to their secure location take
him back to the Watchtower the problem
with this is that they're met with the
arrival of dead man now again this
continues the trend of grabbing these
characters that you know from vertigo
grabbing a lot of these really obscure
characters from the realm of you know
DC's whole magical uh magical side and
bringing them into the story but the way
that they're used is really unique dead
man has a lot of different abilities but
his most notable ability is the ability
to possess other people and that's what
he does he possesses the body of Shazam
and basically engineers the freedom of
John Constantine by basically just
dropping him from the sky now of course
Constantine's rescued by zatana but uh
in response to this he immediately or at
least it seems like he intends to leave
the body of Shazam but this is when dead
man begins to realize that inhabiting
the body of Shazam is not just
inhabiting the body of one man it's
inhabiting the body of Two Men And this
is kind of cool because what this also
shows us is how Billy Batson views the
actions of Superman because keep in mind
in year one we had talked about Billy
badson going around and interviewing all
these different people in terms of what
Superman was doing whether or not they
agreed with what Superman was doing it
was this notion that Billy Bassin
himself was kind of questioning what was
going on from the perspective of a 12 of
a 12-year-old kid he didn't grasp all
these philosophical ideas the people
that Billy Bassam was talking to you
know they were all like well I agree
with Superman well I disagree with
Superman everybody had their own stance
everybody had their own take dead man
tries to talk to Billy Batson and say
hey look you have to see that what
Superman is doing is wrong and Billy
Batson says no I agree with what
Superman is doing he's making the world
a better place but it's kind of kind of
funny because it shows us how far a lot
of these guys have fallen how far a lot
of these guys have gone when it comes to
the idea of looking at Superman and what
it is that he's doing now this all
really seems to come to a head when we
have the Spectre who seizes the body of
Shazam and we basically have him forcing
dead man out of that body now again this
is also Tom Taylor showing us what it is
that the Spectre seems to be able to do
what it is that the Spectre seems to be
capable of but this is also him saying
not everything is what it seems to be
and the reason why is because dead man
looks at Spectre and says you're not Jim
Corgan you're not the Spectre you're
you're you're someone else you're
someone masquerading as the Spectre who
are you like why are you here what are
you doing in this whole situation and
it's crazy because before dead man can
really even you know before he can get
any answers out of this dead man is
basically chopped in half now he's not
totally destroyed I mean again he's
basically a ghost and but his body seems
to be just kind of Fading Into Oblivion
of course he races off but then we pick
up you know back at the tower of Fate
with uh with Batman with John
Constantine with all these different
guys and they're just constantly arguing
bicking you know bickering you know John
Constantine's bickering against Batman
and they basically travel off to the
Green in order to find Swamp Thing
because what Tom Taylor is basically
telling us here is that Swamp Thing is
going to be one of the more important
players in the entirety of this battle
to try to save the Earth against
Superman now Tom Taylor introducing
Swamp Thing into the story is not done
for the sake of just you know fan
service like there's a much bigger
picture here I mean there are a lot of
people out there that love Swamp Thing
but Swamp Thing in the green basically
just means like the the green being what
it is is just kind of like this weird
you know network of plant life it
basically just means that like you know
Swamp Thing can manipulate you know
Plant Organic Matter on the planet Earth
the reason why this matters though is
that in addition to Swamp Thing you know
being Immortal being able to tie into
plant life and so on and so forth is
that where Superman could you know tear
apart trees and the various different
things that that Swamp Thing could
conjure swamp thing's abilities combined
with normal magical abilities would
create a hither to unchallengeable force
on behalf of uh of those individuals who
are working against Superman and so
trying to grab Swamp Thing to their side
would be absolutely massive the issue
with this is that Swamp Thing is more or
less chosen his Allegiance and it
basically seems like he's chosen the
side of Superman and so because of this
they basically don't have Swamp Thing on
their side they really don't have access
to the green they don't have access to
this this ongoing Network they can't
basically see everything that's going on
in the world at the same time instead
they're basically without what would
what would be considered one of their
most important assets in addition to
this we pick back up with dead man we
pick back up with Boston Brand uh who's
basically traveling to see ramach
Krishna now again ramach Krishna was the
one that basically made him dead man
that allowed him to just kind of go and
host you know grab host bodies from one
from one to the other now the whole
basis behind this was that he was
basically the victim of a murder and he
was granted the ability to possess
bodies as a uh as an apparition in order
to gain revenge on the person that
murdered him but you know what happens
is ramach Krishna basically says you're
passing on to the next realm there's
really nothing I can do to save you all
I can do is have somebody else undertake
the mantle of dead man and the person
who's undertaking the mantle of dead man
is Dick Grayson basically dick Grayson's
Spirit has been brought back and Dick
Grayson will exist as a ghostly
Apparition and it's kind of insane here
because it's like wow like I thought
Dick Grayson was dead when the heck did
he come back the issue is that this
doesn't really explain instead it just
seems to be the ghost of Dick Grayson
who's here to operate on behalf of uh of
of ramach Krishna and basically serve as
an opposing Force to the uh to the goal
of of Superman and his team you know
kind of going against and trying to
trying to conquer the world but at this
point it seems to be a matter of trying
to basically find a way to overcome the
notion that Constantine Batman and this
group do not have access to swamp things
abilities they're still just kind of fly
a Flying Blind here but what we do is we
switch over to the Spectre himself and
we join with the arrival of the Phantom
stranger now this is where things get
kind of hairy and the reason why I say
that is because the Phantom stranger is
exactly what he is like no one knows
anything about him he's just a guy that
has incredible powers and it's just like
like him being here is kind of weird
because it's almost almost one of those
things where it's like when the Watcher
shows up in Marvel Comics like when the
when the Phantom stranger shows up it's
like okay things are about to to get
really really bad like something huge is
going to take place the issue with this
is a phantom stranger in the Spectre
kind of exists in the realm of their own
so the Phantom stranger is more of like
an observer that acts every once in a
while but DC always teases this notion
that if the Phantom stranger were to act
it would be like God himself acting and
so you know basically anything the
Phantom stranger wanted to do could be
absolute it's it's reality warping on
the most pure scale the problem with
this is that the Spectre basically you
know exposes himself exposes what he is
to the Phantom stranger and then
destroys the Phantom stranger and so
it's like wow I mean if the Phantom
stranger has been obliterated by the
Spectre then who the heck is the Spectre
like what in the world is going on here
well at this point we basically pick up
with what seems to be rran you know the
arrival of rran here and what takes
place is this conflict you know between
this demon you know with this wild
abilities going against you know
Superman going against uh Sinestro going
against Hal Jordan but what this is
designed to be is a ruse and the reason
why this is designed to be a ruse is
because John cson had been talking with
Batman and they basically said we have
to find a way to take Superman off the
table we have to find a way to remove
him from this equation that's how we did
it with Wonder Woman we used our
abilities we used magic to take Wonder
Woman out that's why she's been
unconscious for so long and so what we
find out is that in this battle between
rran and Superman that this is not
actually rran instead it's actually
Batman and what Batman does is feeds
Superman a handful of pills of sorts
that basically knock him out that
basically put Superman in you know in a
magical enchantment that he doesn't seem
to have the ability to wake up from but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end this is a
weird one I know this one gets a little
strange it seems to go off the rails but
this is one of those where it all makes
sense at the end of year three it all
comes together at the end of year three
but if you guys are new here to Comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the robore if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace